we really can't talk about the Overton
Window moves and creeping normality in
2019 without talking about how extreme
right-wing ideology has become
mainstreamed and is now part of what is
considered legitimate political
discourse in way too many circles
there's a really good piece in The
Guardian about this by Mark Townsend and
machine Iqbal that spells this out and
it's something I've been telling you for
some time now and I encourage you to
read the piece the write in the United
States has very successfully pulled the
discussion around a ton of political
issues to the right and this is a huge
structural advantage for them because
there are too many issues including
abortion immigration and many others
they are winning merely by pulling the
discussion to the extreme right the left
has some wins on this in the United
States so over the last two to three
years we've seen the left insert more
progressive ideas into the mainstream
discussion about health care for example
everybody's talking now about Medicare
for all and other single-payer systems
doesn't mean we're necessarily about to
get them but the debate has been pulled
to the left on health care successfully
by the progressive movement in equality
starting with Occupy Wall Street and
since then with the likes of candidates
like Bernie Sanders and others
inequality has become mainstreamed as an
issue taxation more progressive ideas on
taxation for example but the
radicalization that comes from the right
is truly a danger I'm gonna give you a
specific example the idea of the great
replacement okay the great replacement
is a right-wing nationalist conspiracy
theory that officially started in France
in 2012 by that name but there are many
versions of it and generally it's the
idea that white Christians are going to
be replaced by non-european people brown
people in many cases sometimes not
Christians and it's going to destroy
everything and it's going to be terrible
and there are versions of this that date
back decades hundreds of years even
longer maybe I guess I'd have to think
about it without being called the great
replacement but the idea has been around
for a long time this fear of the other
the other is going to come in and
replace us and take our
status in society and maybe take our
riches or maybe take our women right I
mean there's the different versions of
this great replacement idea but it has
been used to stoke nationalist extremist
ideas and it's been around for a long
time here in the United States white
nationalists and other right-wingers
have been pushing this for years in
relation specifically to immigration
policy and usually it relates to Latin
American immigrants and it has
unfortunately become mainstream they've
succeeded at this it's on Fox News all
the time it's not fringe websites that
are talking about this it has infected
what is considered mainstream right-wing
political thinking Fox News host Laura
Ingraham did a segment in August which
we covered basically a sanitized great
replacement segment about legal and
illegal immigrants forcing demographic
change in the United States and
destroying the country by doing it
Tucker Carlson on Fox News very similar
thing numerous segments one in which he
said that brown people coming to the
United States legally becoming citizens
and voting in elections is a form of
election hacking this is fundamentally
it's a great replacement sort of
conspiracy theory another segment in
which Tucker Carlson ranted about
immigrants making our country dirtier
this type of discussion at one point was
not considered serious conversation on
these issues I still would have
disagreed with what the right thought at
the time but they were not overtly
radical in this particular way that I'm
showing you the Institute for Strategic
Dialogue has been studying this and
they've found that these formerly sort
of obscure ideas are now everywhere
Donald Trump references them in speeches
on Twitter it's happening in European
countries among the nationalist parties
it's all over social media particularly
on Twitter even outside of the
president's own tweets the write likes
to say that there's left-wing bias just
implicit in all of our discussions and
on media and they love the example of
Twitter is left-wing because if you
misgender people on purpose
you could get banned this is a joke
compared to the reality that straight up
xenophobic almost phrenologist type
look that up if you don't remember what
that is is now part of the discussion
around many of these issues they have
slick branding they come up with wording
that makes it sound relatively innocuous
if you're not paying close enough
attention but they are pushing extreme
ideas into the gray area of valid
political discussion and it has the
effect that is beneficial for them of
pulling the Overton Window seriously to
the right the rights slick branding has
pushed extreme right-wing ideas into
mainstream discourse they've
successfully integrated them into even
corporate media discussions of many
political issues while at the same time
continuing to shout that there's
inherent left-wing bias in all media and
social platforms this is one of the most
successful disinformation campaigns of
the last thirty years and what we all
need to understand is that even if the
craziest ideas that they espouse aren't
made into reality they're not made into
policy it makes the marginally less
crazy ideas seem middle-of-the-road in
comparison and that's the danger of the
mainstreaming of extremist nationalist
right-wing ideas of the Overton Window
being pushed to the right and of the
creeping normalization that we've
experienced over the last 15 years but
particularly over the last two and a
half under Donald Trump I want to hear
from you about this do you agree with my
assessment and how do you think we fight
it I'm on Twitter at D Pakman please
follow me there and follow the david
pakman show on twitter as well